but I live at your [ __ ] storage place
if you wanted to oh so if I said I want
to rent this storage room but I want to
live here as well you wouldn't kick me
out I wouldn't but if you could survive
what do you mean because it's pitch
black man not if it's a thing but if I
what if I set up a generator there's no
there's no there's no Outlets there's
it's dark as we operate under a smart
smart lighting system yeah it only turns
on if someone's there or moving oh yeah
so if I'm constantly moving the lights
are on if I'm constantly moving the
lights are on
so if I'm watching TV I'll be constantly
moving what do you think you open a box
of sweating and then there's no shower
or bathroom shower or no bathroom what
if I have a portable one you know how
you they have construction sites oh like
a porta potty a porta potty in the
[ __ ] storage room and I set up a
little bed there and have a little
gasoline generator right so I'm going
right would you let me to live there
yeah sure [ __ ] yeah yeah let's move
there
are you trying to get back with me no
different storage rooms
yeah yeah so you have your own storage
do they have like a storage award you
know you know what storage is yeah I do
the TV show the TV show yeah yeah do
they have that here we're gonna have one
here because right now we have around
eight abandoned units
oh we'd love to do that oh that would be
so fun to just kind of sift through yeah
yeah but what do they have their coconut
shell I mean
what's in a Filipino [ __ ] coconut
shell yeah if it's somebody is that
racist I'm sorry
that it can afford like long-term
storage it's probably someone who has
money so like yeah but then what
happened when they can't pay the rent so
why can I tell you what's in his storage
right now he doesn't even know he has a
storage oh you have a storage right I do
foreign
yeah you pay for it every month who pays
for it you I want to stop paying what
you're going to lose weight no I wanted
to see it on Storage Wars that'd be cool
they'd be very disappointed right so
when we when I first I know what's
happening
let me guess
my toys
so many like still in their boxes cool
cool freaking thousands of dollars worth
of toys yeah
and what else paintings
um some Yeah but I this your your shoe
game is unmatched wait my shoes are in
the [ __ ] storage I mean like really
cool shoes yeah I want to go old school
Air Maxes I've been looking for those
you have not been looking yes I haven't
I've been looking for my [ __ ] shoes
man well now you know that I go through
it with jules's closet and I'm always
looking I go where are those shoes I
used to wear you they're you don't you
have like cowboy boots I love cowboy
boots yeah so so where's the storage
um it's in downtown L.A all right and
when can I go visit you just want to see
him let's just say I want to see what's
in there man um yeah I want to know
what's it because I thought I lost him
over the years yeah so it makes me sad
so you have eight abandoned units eight
amended units yeah wow so um half of it
from Americans
oh here we go that's where the money is
Americans huh are they x-pacs expense
did you say x-pacs what'd I say X-Pac s
that's what I said what
it's supposed to be x-pacs all right
patents pets expatriates that's what it
said yeah a XPS
other expats yeah yeah yeah let me ask
you something about here let me say
something okay do you see this
in Thailand
what your Thailand story is All In
involved Lucy no no